the story of the m2 macbook air leaks  started around six months ago from john  prosser from front page tech he revealed  exclusive renders of that m2 macbook air  but recently we just got some fresh  leaks and they are very controversial  the same notch that i have right here on  this 16 inch macbook pro in white that  honestly looks kind of bad now this  particular leak came from dylan dkt on  twitter now apple says they were able to  basically thin down the bezels like  crazy as you can see right here by  adding that notch in so my thought is  what if apple is not going to give us  those crazy thin bezels on the m2  macbook air and they're going to give us  the thicker bezels and basically kind of  force us to spend more money if we want  super thin bezels by only going for the  macbook pro